>> From the Library of Congress in Washington,
D.C.
>> Author Sherri Duskey Rinker has wonderful
memories of reading with her grandmother as
a young girl.
And since becoming a mom, she creates new
memories reading regularly with her son.
We're fortunate that she's also written many
children's books of her own so that we could
actually read together with our own loved
ones.
Her books include "Good Night, Good Night,
Construction Site," "Silly, Wonderful You,"
and the "Steam Train, Dream Train" books.
Author-illustrator John Rocco has also brought
us many children's books.
I bet you read some of these yourself.
"Moonpowder."
"Blizzard."
"Blackout."
"Wolf, Wolf."
"Fu Finds a Way."
Or "Beep!
Beep!
Go to Sleep!"
Well, their new book "Big Machines" the story
of Virginia Lee Burton comes out this week.
And you can meet the authors and have books
signed between 11:30 and 12:30 p.m. today.
So let's give a warm welcome to Sherri Duskey
Rinker and John Rocco.
^M00:01:20
[ Applause ]
^M00:01:27
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: Hi guys.
>> Hi.
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: Oh, my word.
That was kind of lame.
Hi!
>> Hi!
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: I'm so excited to
be here.
Are you guys excited?
>> Yes.
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: Woo!
Okay.
So I'm Sherri Duskey Rinker.
Oh, I should've had you guess which one of
us was Sherri Duskey Rinker and which one
was John Rocco.
Would you have been able to guess?
>> John Rocco: I'm Sherri.
[laughter]
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: You could guess.
I know.
So we're here to tell you a story.
Did you want to say something, John?
I'm a microphone hog.
>> John Rocco: I just wanted to say hello.
Good morning.
>> Good morning.
>> For coming to the Library of Congress town
square.
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: Okay.
All right.
So John and I wrote a story.
We got an idea together for a book.
And just like all stories that are awesomely
great, our story starts out -- how did it
start out?
What does that say?
Once upon a time.
We, in a land called "Folley Cove "-- and
there's a picture of Folley Cove far, far,
far away -- or maybe about an eight hour drive
from here.
There lived a very magical person.
And this you may already guess is Virginia
Lee Burton, who's an author and an illustrator
and gave us amazing, amazing books like "Mike
Mulligan and his Steam Shovel" or "The Little
House."
Do any of you know those stories?
Some of you.
[applause] So, as we were researching all
about Virginia Lee Burton, we learned some
amazing things about her.
Like she was a dancer.
Do any of you take dancing lessons?
Some of you?
And she even when she was young she loved
to write stories.
Do any of you like writing stories?
Me too.
And she liked to draw and do art.
And this is a picture of her in her studio.
And she loved to teach.
When I was young, I loved to play school.
Did any of you like that?
Love playing school.
Well, Virginia Lee Burton grew up to be a
teacher and to teach people how to do art.
She had a special technique where she cut
things out of wood or linoleum and made pictures.
And then they would ink up the linoleum plate
and they would put paper or fabric on them
and they would step on it.
And they would peel off the paper or fabric.
And this is the art they created.
You can see me holding it.
Go ahead.
>> John Rocco: I want to interject for a second.
If you notice in this picture, do you see
what's on her skirt?
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: And the curtains.
>> John Rocco: Do you see the unicorns and
the trees?
So she made that art and then she made her
own clothes.
Which I thought was pretty cool.
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: She decorated her
own clothes.
And her own things around her house like her
curtains and her place mats and tablecloths.
And so did this whole group of people that
she taught how to do this.
So you can see.
And then when John and I were researching
for our book, we got to meet her son.
Do you recognize John in that picture?
He looks different, doesn't he?
What's different about John?
Yeah, he shaved off his beard.
Do you like the beard or you like him clean
like this? [inaudible speaker] You like the
beard?
Clean?
Yeah.
>> John Rocco: Okay.
We need to take a vote.
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: Okay.
We'll take a vote later.
>> John Rocco: Maybe I'll grow it back.
[laughter]
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: So we got to hold
some of the original things that Virginia
Lee Burton created.
And that's us with her son.
His name is Aristides.
And this is a piece of art that was created
from that piece I was holding.
And this is her group of designers that she
inspired in Folley Cove.
This is Virginia Burton.
She was an amazing, joyful, vivacious person
that people loved to be around.
She made people smile just by being the personality
she was.
And she loved acting and dancing and throwing
big, spectacular parties.
And she loved her garden.
And they inspired her to create her art.
And she loved animals.
And that also inspired her.
But mostly she loved -- because she was a
mom -- can you guess?
Her boys.
She had two sons.
Aristides, her oldest.
And Michael.
And this is her with her husband George and
the boys.
And just like I have done, I was inspired
to write because of the things my boys loved.
And she was inspired to write because of the
things her boys loved.
So, Aristides loved trains.
Any of you train people?
So, I wrote a book called "Steam Train, Dream
Train."
And John did a book called "How to Train a
So we both really love trains too.
And Aristides liked trains.
So Jinnee wrote a book for Aristides called
-- what is it called?
"Choo Choo."
And Michael loved steam shovels.
This is a steam shovel -- an actual steam
shovel from a long time ago.
And Jinnee looked at the steam shovels and
she created -- do any of you know this book?
Mike Mulligan -- you have it?
Well, that's awesome.
It's such a great story.
So, Jinnee wrote lots of books all inspired
really by her kids and the things she loved.
She wrote "Choo Choo" and "Mike Mulligan"
and "Calico the Wonder Horse" because her
kids liked comic books.
"The Little House."
"Katy and the Big Snow."
"The Saw and the Robin Hood" which is John's
favorite Jinnee Burton book.
"Maybelle the Cable Car."
And "Life Story."
She was inspired by everything around her
to write and create.
Most especially her boys but her garden and
the beautiful place where she lived and the
animals around her.
And all of that inspired us.
>> John Rocco: That was great, Sherri.
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: Thanks, John.
>> John Rocco: So I want to talk to you a
little bit about how Virginia Lee Burton went
about creating books because in the process
of making this book I was very inspired by
how she made the pictures and how she designed
the book.
This is a page from her book "Choo Choo."
And if you look on the left-hand side, you
can see the text.
And on the right-hand side, you see the picture.
Now she made these books a long, long time
ago.
Eighty -- almost 80 years ago or more.
Some of them.
And so there wasn't a precedent -- there wasn't
so many ways to make children's books.
Usually, it was, okay.
The words go on one side.
The picture goes on the other.
And in this case, she did that as well.
But you see how she laid out the words?
Do you see how the train is moving from the
city to the country?
And how it's winding its way over those hills?
She decided to emulate that movement with
the words.
And that helped tell the story.
And as you read her books, you'll see that
this kind of design would go into all of her
books.
In this book which is about "Katy and the
Big Snow," you can see that she incorporated
the text into the picture.
So I'll read it.
Then after she had found the broken down truck
plows, she started home.
^M00:09:21 The fire department had put out
the fire.
And there you see the fire trucks.
The doctor had saved his patient.
And you see the little ambulance.
The water department had repaired the main.
The telephone and electricity were on.
The mail could go through.
And the police could protect the city.
Thanks to what Katy did.
So you see how the text and the image work
together?
They're almost in this dance.
That's one of the incredible things that Virginia
Lee Burton brought to children's books.
It was no longer about text on one side, picture
on the other.
She started to integrate the words and the
pictures to help tell her story.
You can see from this image from "Maybelle
the Cable Car" how the words actually connect
the two drawings into one bigger shape or
bigger design.
No hill too step for Maybelle.
No matter what the weather -- wet or dry -- she
could not slip.
She had her grip.
And three kinds of brakes besides.
"Ting, ting, ting."
And you can see this image.
You might be familiar from "Mike Mulligan
and the Steam Shovel" where Mary Ann, the
steam shovel, is just digging away at the
dirt.
And there's smoke flying.
And there's steam coming out of the engine.
So you can see how she used patterns and designs
to create this circular motion.
And not only does it create a sense of motion
but it creates a sense of energy.
You can see how strong and powerful Mary Ann
is as she digs away at that hole with just
the sun peeking out from the clouds.
And you can see this kind of patterning in
the book "The Little House."
You see the clouds going across the sky.
A little cloud.
A little bit bigger cloud.
An even bigger cloud.
And a bigger cloud.
Same with the trees.
And you can see these overlapping shapes that
help make the image.
Now the wonderful thing about the little house,
if you look at it again -- and I had this
experience as a kid when I looked at the book
"The Little House" which was that the house,
itself, never moves as you turn the page from
this page to this page.
Nothing happens to the house.
It stays in the same spot.
It's the same size.
And the world around the house keeps changing.
And that was the one of the incredible things
because it was almost like,, what's going
on here?
The house, which is what the story's about,
is right there in the center.
And everything around it is changing.
And that book is about change.
When Virginia Lee Burton and her husband first
bought their home in Folley Cove, they actually
picked it up and moved it away from the road.
And I think that was the inspiration for this
book.
Was the idea that we don't want to be so close
to everything that's happening.
We want to be back a little bit.
And that's what eventually happens with the
little house in the book.
They pick it up and they move it back to the
country as the city built up around it.
So what we'd like to do is read the book.
Sherri's going to read it to you.
And as she's reading it, I'm going to try
to draw some of the characters from Virginia
Lee Burton's stories.
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: Okay.
You guys ready?
All right.
So all of this stuff about Jinnee Burton was
so inspiring that's what inspired us to create
our book.
So I'm going to read.
John's going to draw along.
And everyone root for John cause he was worried
he couldn't keep up.
So come on.
Let's say, Go, John.
Go, John.
Okay.
You ready?
Here we go.
"Big machines."
The story of Virginia Lee Burton.
Who, by the way, was my favorite author growing
up when I was growing up.
And I hope you can see how pretty John's illustrations
are.
I love them.
This is Virginia Lee but everyone in seaside
Folley Cove simply calls her "Jinnee."
Anyone who meets Jinnee will tell you that
she is quite magical.
[pause] She makes things grow in an enchanted
garden.
She talks to the chickens and the sheep.
And even the little pit mouse.
And, of course, they share all their secrets.
[pause] And everyone who knows Jinnee will
tell you she can fly.
But of all the very special things about Jinnee
perhaps what's most amazing about her is what
she creates with her very magical wands.
What are her wands?
Can you tell?
They're her art materials.
Right?
That's how she creates her magic.
With a few taps of a wand, Jinnee creates
animals.
She can also make the seasons change.
And conjure heroes and horses and people of
all sorts.
And even a very good dinosaur.
But for her sons Aristides and Michael, she
makes the most wonderful things of all.
The things they love best.
Big machines.
[pause] It begins with a line.
Black and rough.
Then a squiggle.
And a rub.
As little Aristides watches, a puff of smoke
appears.
Clears.
And then, Woo!
Woo!
A whistle cries.
Do more!
Do more, Aristides shouts in return.
So Jinnee draws and draws.
It's a train.
I see a train, says Aristides.
With each sweep Choo Choo comes more to life.
She zips and zooms down the tracks.
So Jinnee draws and draws.
Choo Choo rings her bell.
And with Jinnee's magic, begins to tell the
story of the time that Choo Choo escaped.
To Aristides's delight, Choo Choo chugs off
to exciting, even dangerous adventures.
But, of course, in the end, she always comes
home safely.
Michael loves watching big trucks hard at
work.
Good job, John.
[applause] Woo!
Okay.
Are we ready?
>> John Rocco: I'm ready.
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: Okay.
Now he is going to draw Mary Ann the steam
shovel.
Michael loves watching big trucks hard at
work digging and building.
Constantly moving.
And so Jinnee watches trucks too.
She observes patiently.
Closely.
And she begins.
First, the lines.
This time layered and sketchy.
Then the circles.
Then the brush bursts of red.
A rumble.
A power.
Before dirt flies.
And right before Michael's eyes, a bucket
loads and lifts clearing earth to make canals.
Cutting through mountains for railways.
Leveling land for highways and runways.
Digging deep into the earth making foundations.
Smoke blows from her stack.
There loud and proud, strong and steely, always
hard at work Mary Ann.
A steam shovel.
Michael jumps with joy.
Now Michael has a truck to call his very own
and Michael and Mary Ann smile at each other.
Friends forever.
And soon more big machines burst to life.
First, there -- [inaudible speaker] Oh, okay.
>> John Rocco: That's okay.
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: John's behind.
Do you want me to keep going or do you want
me to slow down and sing something?
>> John Rocco: No, I'll catch up.
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: Oh, okay.
And soon more big machines burst to life.
First, there's just paper.
White.
Jinnee touches it.
And pop.
With a whoosh of black.
Some strokes of red and green.
Aristides and Michael meet Katy.
Katy is a beautiful bright crawler tractor.
She can roll on her thick, black treads.
She can plow with a bulldozer blade -- she
can push with a bulldozer blade attached.
But best of all Katy can plow.
The city of Geopolis is buried in a giant
winter storm and the people are counting on
Katy.
She's the only one big and strong enough to
clear the way.
Katy is rough, tough, and ready to plow the
miles and piles of snow.
No amount of snow can stop her.
Follow me she says as she revs.
And with a "chug, chug, chug," Katy is off
to dig out the town of Geopolis while Aristides
and Michael cheer her on.
^M00:18:26 Jinnee makes more lines.
This time wavy and curvy, swoopy and swervy.
Like music lines flow along.
Color joins in free and watery.
[Background music] And soon -- [laughter]
"Ting, ting, ting."
There is Maybelle the cable car climbing up
and down the giant hills of San Francisco.
Our day is not done.
It's just begun she sings while Aristides
and Michael wave "clingity, cling."
Maybelle rolls away to do the job she loves.
And there's a picture of Jinnee with the actual
Maybelle.
We have five minutes, John.
Keep drawing.
Next, Jinnee makes a little house.
Pink and smiling surrounded by apple trees
on a hill covered with daisies.
That doesn't seem like our kind of story,
say the boys pouting.
Don't worry, says Jinnee as she keeps working.
Suddenly before their eyes, Mary Ann is there.
Then cars appear racing along.
Tractor and trolley cars.
And there a tow truck pulls a car with a flat.
Trains and buses.
Even a subway.
Big construction vehicles roll in smoky and
strong hauling heavy loads.
Jinnee draws and draws.
Roads.
Buildings.
Traffic.
People all in a hurry.
It's much too much.
Skies darken.
The little house sags.
And Aristides and Michael are worried.
And then just like that the little pink house
is saved by a truck.
The boys jump up.
That truck is a hero.
The truck saved the day.
Jinnee smiles to herself.
Well, of course, they see it that way.
Choo Choo and Mary Ann, Katy, Maybelle, and
all of the trucks around the little house
big, powerful heroes, hard working, and happy
and each special and wonderful.
Just like Jinnee.
And that is how here in Folley Cove Jinnee's
big machines and their stories come to life
quite magically.
For Aristides and Michael.
And for you.
^M00:20:58
[ Applause ]
^M00:21:03
>> John Rocco: Nice job.
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: Okay.
So we are not taking questions but we're signing.
And we would love to hear your questions and
hear your stories and things you want to tell
us at our signing line so, please, do come
over.
And -- is there anything else?
>> John Rocco: Yeah.
I just wanted to ask you Sherri, when you
thought about writing this book, as a children's
book author-illustrator, what possessed you
to write a book about Virginia Lee Burton?
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: When I was growing
up, Jinnee Burton was my favorite children's
book author.
I grew up with "The Little House."
It was the first story I remember writing
-- reading.
It was a story my grandma read to me.
And when I became a children's book author,
it was my dream to write a story that would
somehow pay tribute to this amazing woman
who was so far ahead of her time.
She ran a business.
She raised children.
She grew for her garden.
She canned and cooked and had parties.
And taught.
And I think she inspired me.
The more that I read about her, the more that
I researched I was inspired to tell everyone
that the world should know what an incredible,
creative talent she was and how much ahead
of her time that she was.
She was born in 1909 and lived the biggest
part of her life during the depression and
the years immediately following when she was
raising kids and did so much with so little.
So I hope that you guys learned a little bit
about her and that maybe, maybe, maybe you
are starting to love her just as much as I
do.
So thank you so much for coming.
[applause] Oh.
And can we give those away, John?
>> John Rocco: Sure.
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: Okay.
We're going to give John's drawings away.
Is that okay?
[applause] Two?
>> John Rocco: So I want to try to teach you
guys how to draw Mary Ann.
If you want to learn how to draw Mary Ann
very simply, she's made up of a bunch of shapes.
And I think you guys all know how to draw
a circle.
Right?
And do you know how to draw a rectangle?
Yeah.
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: We'll wrap it up.
>> John Rocco: And we'll wrap it up.
Is that what you're saying?
[laughter] Oh, okay.
I'm just going to quickly draw the shapes
so you guys can draw it at home.
Okay?
^M00:23:20
^M00:23:26
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: Rectangle.
[pause] Another rectangle.
I'm here stating the obvious.
Rectangle.
>> A square.
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: Oh.
More of a square.
Yeah, you're right.
Oh, that's the mouth.
She has -- wait.
^M00:23:50
^M00:23:54
>> Sherri Duskey Rinker: Oval.
Circle.
[pause] Oh, awesome, John.
Okay.
Everyone give John a big round of applause.
[applause] Thank you so so so much.
^M00:24:11
>> This has been a presentation of the Library
of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.